[Applause]
it's Halloween it's actually now
oh I love holloway d lavalla we I'd love
Halloween
everything's orange and black like John
Boehner at a Funeral kids dress up as
imaginary creatures like goblins and
vampires and billionaires who pay taxes
crazy imaginary you know what the big
scare this year is I love this because
marijuana you know is so much more
available legal in two states medical
all up yeah they're worried people are
gonna be giving out edibles you know to
trick-or-treaters right like I'm gonna
waste my stash on children let me say
and we we have much bigger problems this
Halloween like if you see a teenage with
a bloody knife you don't know if that's
a costume or he's running away to join
Isis that's what
don't start with me it's [ __ ]
Halloween okay I I love on Halloween to
see what famous people do as a get up
you know what they dress up as I saw a
Renee Zellweger is going as Daryl Hannah
I saw John McCain on TV direct is the
Cryptkeeper or maybe that was just
joking not Delia
oh and Rick Perry is wearing his clothes
backwards not cos it's Halloween that
just sometimes happens with me I got my
customer pick out I'm going as sexy a
bullet nurse get all the groaning out of
your system no I love Halloween during
any a bola scare because nothing says
that we are a modern medically
sophisticated society that really
understands infectious disease like hey
kids fan out and eat things from
strangers
[Music]
have you been following exploits of this
nurse kaci Hickox look once she was
quarantined in New Jersey now she's back
home in Maine boy she's a feisty one she
says if you don't come to her house for
trick-or-treating you're a [ __ ]
and she's coughing on the candy right no
I mean let's not lose fact side of the
fact you know she's heroic she was over
there in Sierra Leone doing volunteer
work stopping this disease she comes
home from Sierra Leone and Chris
Christie because she flew into New
Jersey confined her in a tent and she
was not having it
she said Chris Christie is not a doctor
she said he doesn't know anything about
the human body and no she said that and
he said that's not fair I know a lot
about ribs
oh no Chris
chris christie has got his swagger back
on this issue yeah you see him he's
telling people to shut the [ __ ] up again
he's he's the old chris Christie so he
had to lay low for a long time because
remember that little scandal he had
Bridgegate so he couldn't yell at people
he couldn't act mad he couldn't really
be himself it's been a long time since
we've seen his balls it's been a long
time since he's seen as well again
because he's a large man but here's the
latest today a judge up in Maine told
nurse kaci Hickox that she could self
monitor pretty much which is great
because that's what she was gonna do
anyway did you see her this B she went
on a bike ride with a boyfriend I tell
you these doctors without borders' when
they say without borders they're not
[ __ ] around it's a type of person you
could only ever find in America a
selfless humanitarian who also has
narcissistic personality disorder
and it's funny because
the other day when Casey and her
boyfriend got back from their bike trip
the reporters wanted to know where in
Maine they went and one of the reporters
yelled out Bangor and her boyfriend said
no you Chris it's a tribute to an old
joke not an old joke itself no everyone
up there in Maine is nervous now today
somebody spotted a bear [ __ ] in the
woods I'm telling you it is but for
those people panicking let me remind
everybody a bola has still killed fewer
people in America than OJ and you know
it should really not even be a political
issue which it has become you know that
there are certain conservatives now who
are selling bumper stickers that say a
bola Obama's legacy to America I know
nice right they wanted to use Black
Plague but it was too on the nose
okay other big story this week you saw
Tim Cook the CEO of Apple the biggest
company in the world came out as gay you
hear that conservatives you've got a gay
phone in your pocket
oh you know what
I kinda suspected this because a couple
of weeks ago I asked Siri I said sorry
we're in the neighborhood can I get a
nice dinner and she said in that outfit